are you struggling with not having
enough time to do your YouTube videos do
you feel like you're overwhelmed and you
just can't get it all done well in
today's video myself and Melissa Caputo
from the think media team are going to
be walking you through through three of
our time management apps that we love
and three tips for time management but
Melissa how are you doing today I'm
doing great Heather I am so excited to
learn these tips they are things that I
need in my everyday life and I'm excited
to hear again the things that you're
asking me to do every day because it's
just good to reinforce so this is gonna
be good
awesome well I'm excited let's just go
ahead and jump into it today Mel we're
gonna be covering the three free time
management apps and tips that will make
you so much more productive and then
after that we're going to do a Q&A so
you can jump in with any of your
questions that you have and we will get
to those but first if you want to follow
on social media or you want to share
this stream with someone you can follow
me over at miss Heather Torres and use
the hashtag think marketing this is the
think marketing show the think marketing
YouTube channel and so you can use that
hashtag anytime you are sharing the
things here but one of the questions
that I get a lot is how do you keep this
going and what I mean how do you keep
this going for me that looks like this
so my current role right now is the
chief operations officer of think media
that is a company where we have a
YouTube channel of over a million
subscribers we're a multi seven-figure
company and we run a team of about 10
people here in Las Vegas and around the
country and beyond just that how do I
keep that going I'm the host of this
think marketing podcast along with that
I am a wife and a mother and I also
homeschool my three kids
yeah so you probably think she is crazy
how does she get it all done well today
I'm going to be sharing with you three
of those tips of how I do that and let
me ask you this question and tell me in
the chat if you know
if you can answer this question do you
relate to this do you feel overwhelmed
burnt out or just plain tired when it
comes to doing YouTube I know for me it
is something I have felt before and so
I'm excited to share some let me know in
the chat if you felt that way by giving
me a number one in the chat if you felt
like that number two in the chat if you
have not so let me know and then also
can you relate to feeling like not
having enough time I think for me that
is a huge deal in what that looks like
and I want to share this quote with you
the quote with you is if you don't
prioritize prioritize your life someone
else will this is from a book that that
I read that I really love and and I
think that it was a really great i
opening for me because I always just
recognized time as something that we all
have that we could all use and so let's
see this is a really great thing to
think about
everyone has 24 hours in their day it's
what you do with those hours that makes
a difference everyone has 24 hours in a
day and it's what you do with that that
makes a difference so this quote here is
really great I want you to write this
one down you have to say no to a lot of
good things in order to be able to say
yes to great things you have to say no
to a lot of good things in order to say
yes to a lot of great things and for me
personally being a homeschooling mom who
works full-time this is one practice
that I had to learn that changed my life
that lesson is time management and so
today we're going to be sharing a three
of our time management apps that Melissa
and I use that we love and that are free
because I love a love f REE free is my
favorite and the first one is Google
Calendar let me know in the chat do you
do you use Google Calendar I love Google
Calendar for so many reasons but the
main reason is because it is a digital
calendar that not only you can have
access to but you can share with other
people in your life I think it's really
important that the
in your life know what's going on and I
love that you can color-code hello any
other color coders out there you could
let me know in the chat the color coding
is amazing and I love that Google
Calendar is a desktop and an app so you
can use it on your on your iPhone or you
can use it on your desktop PC Mac it
goes for everything it's a browser-based
software and I love Google Calendar the
second free app that we use for time
management here at think media and in my
life is Trello Trello is a project
management software this is free they do
have paid versions but I love the free
version and I think it's really
important that you think about what are
you planning what are the projects that
are in your life this can be for work
and for personal things and do you
remember when we were young and we used
to put sticky notes everywhere well I
still do that but now it's digitalized
and I do that through Trello so projects
can be planned through cello - through
Trello by making them organized into
what category you would like you can
shift the cards around there's so much
functionality when it comes to Trello
let me know in the chat have you used
Trello and if you haven't are you gonna
download it and then the third app that
I love it's a free app it's called
rescue time now you do have a feature on
an iPhone if you do have a newer iPhone
where it can do some time tracking for
you but here's what I love about rescue
time rescue time is a software where it
tells you how many times have you gone
on your phone or your web browsers what
type of content are you searching or
being on online it gives you an actual
update so you can see how much time are
you spending on social media apps
reading news doing things that are
productive and doing things that are
unproductive rescue time has been a
really great app for me to actually be
clued into I think sometimes you have to
recognize what am I actually doing with
my time especially when you are around
devices all day what are you doing with
the with the with the phone and with the
computer and this is a really great app
to help you with that I love that it
tracks per hour and then it will also
give you update so it'll be like heads
up you're doing a
out of work outside of your normal
working hours so you can set up certain
reminders so that this app can help you
track your time more well those are
three of our apps that we love here I
think media I would love to know in the
comments if you use those apps and let's
move on to our time management tips our
time management tips well here at think
marketing and at think media we have a
quote that we say what good scheduled
gets done it is so important to remember
that what you put on your calendar is
actually what gets done let me know if
you can relate to this I have this lofty
goal of organizing my closet I I really
like I really want to be able to
organize my closet but it just keeps
getting pushed over to another day to
another day to another weekend to
another weekend and for me I can tell
you the reason for that is because I've
not planned out the project it seems
really daunting I've got to go through
all my spring clothes I've got a you
know organize all the shoes yeah I want
to redo the drawers and I haven't
actually planned out the project I
haven't even thought about when is it
actually going to get done and so here
at think media we say what gets
scheduled gets done so this is a big
part of my life it's called calendar
blocking here's a time management tip
for you start calendar blocking now
calendar blocking is a time management
method that schedules your day into set
controlled units set controlled units
rather than having a bunch of things on
your calendar you actually start to
block your calendar off and here's a
preview of what my calendar looks like I
do things like my family time which
right currently is in purple I have my
IPAs which are my income-producing
activities those happen in yellow I have
my red which is my homeschooling time
with my kids my husband and I switch off
on that I have yellow I'm sorry I have
blue which is working on my own side
hustle and projects that I love to do
and then I have admin and other things
scheduled on there but you'll see I like
to work within the time blocks because
it helps me to stay focus and here are
some benefits of time blocking time
blocking helps you to recognize
your priorities when you fill up your
calendar first with the things that are
important and prioritized for you you'll
start to see movement not only in your
business but in your life I love the it
helps you consider how long to spend on
different tasks you have to think about
it before you actually jump into it is
this gonna take me an hour to edit this
video or do you think it's gonna take
you five hours to edit the video well
that's gonna change let you put on your
time block it also helps you to schedule
according to your own working
preferences now one of the things I love
about being a freedom like a working in
a business that is around our lifestyle
and freedom is that we can work when we
want from where we want with the people
that matter most to us we are we can be
around those people when it matters most
we're not locked into nine-to-five now
that might not be the same for you but
you could be working towards when is the
best time for you to be shooting your
videos when is the best time for you to
be editing your videos really thinking
through do you like working on a
Saturday do you not like working on a
Saturday those are all things that you
can actually start to prioritize when
you're doing your calendar blocking all
right another time management tip for
you is to plan your projects from start
to finish all right let me know in the
chat if you're getting value out of this
I'm gonna take a quick sip of water let
me know in the chat if you are loving
this today plan out your projects from
start to finish I love this quote by
Paul Meyer he says productivity is never
an accident it is always the result of a
commitment to excellence intelligent
planning and focused effort I want you
to be planning your projects from start
to finish that's what's great about
using calendar blocking like Trello and
using I'm sorry using calendar blocking
like Google Calendar and using project
management software's like Trello you're
able to plan from start to finish what
does this process gonna look like what
am I gonna need to do to accomplish this
goal it's very important that you break
down your projects into bite-sized
pieces so you can finalize them through
the project management software all
right so let's move on and the last tip
that I love is
to shut out distractions now the actual
app that I showed you was the rescue
time the rescue timer app I loved and it
actually helps me to really refocus
about what distractions are around me
it's hard sometimes when you've got kids
running around or you're trying to edit
that video or you know you really just
you need to get those titles and
descriptions done it can be so hard
because you want to jump on social media
you want to join the conversations you
want to be everywhere or have the
notifications going off so one of the
key pieces for me is actually
eliminating the distractions I've shut
off all notifications on my phone
sometimes I'll put it in airplane mode
I'll close all the tabs on my computer I
don't have the notifications coming on
because I want to be well focused on the
work that I am doing this is important
focused hard work is the real key to
success jumping around from project to
project and from task to task is really
hard to get things moving forward it's
when you can be focused it would win you
can work hard and be within the time
blocks that matter most to you that can
move you forward well I am excited to
share with you some of our think
marketing resources we have three books
right now that we recommend for you to
grab for the month of June that's
essentialism atomic habits and deep work
those are the three books I recommend
you can get those in the description box
below if you want to click on over to
Amazon you can also get those on
audibles if you are like me and like to
auditory learn and then we also have the
think media tools calm if you are
wondering what software are you guys
using right now and how are you able to
do this live stream like this on YouTube
and and show your slides and if you're
wondering what kind of I need an editor
or how do i do thumbnails or what are
some other time management tools you
guys use here I think marketing this is
the place for you you can go to think
media tools calm and that will help you
navigate through all of the tools that
we use and recommend here I think
marketing and at think media well I am
excited because I have Melissa Caputo on
with me today
and we are going to be jumping into your
QA we're gonna be jumping into the QA
that you have right now Melissa how are
you doing I am doing great Heather I
think it's it's so every time we talk
about time management and you guys this
is one of Heather's favorite topics
because she is the point pioneers on her
team trying to get everybody organized
and everybody focused on their tasks and
getting stuff done she has to wrangle
all this so if anybody knows about time
management it is Heather Torres and
Heather has been teaching me time
blocking for a while now and I want to
say it that way because this is not
something that all of us are going to
implement one day and then do perfectly
from here on out for me it is really
difficult I even though Heather and I
are on the more administrative
administrative side of things in the
company and think media and we're
definitely more of the people who are
doing marketing and operations like we
both have those that kind of creative
brain still that will we'll get really
deep into whatever we're working on and
then sometimes like we just want to get
lost in it and that's the kind of state
that I get into where then all of a
sudden nothing on my calendar matter yes
and I'm like oops I was supposed to be
moving like three different time blocks
right now so it's still something that
is really challenging for me personally
and I I just want to work I don't want
to do all this scheduling I don't want
to spend all this time marking off my
calendar but what heather has been
teaching me what she has to keep
teaching me is that you know it's when
you put in that ten minutes of work or
that you know hour of work on a Sunday
or Monday before you start your week it
sets yourself up for success for the
rest of the week it is worth the time to
practice these things and I was just
talking with somebody in chat about the
idea that like discipline is a muscle
and these things are this is discipline
making a calendar a schedule and then
sticking to it is something you have to
be disciplined to do because most of us
hit you know 2:00 p.m. or 3:00 p.m. or
whatever that time is for you and also
near
like um I'm pretty tired I'm just gonna
like look at my phone for a second and
then it's like an hour later and you've
been completely zoned out and missed
everything you're supposed to do I'm not
saying I do that Heather just saying I
know other people do that but you know
we we have to be disciplined to stick to
our schedules and accomplish the tasks
that we're needing to do and discipline
is a muscle you have to work on it over
time and you have to practice it and so
all of this stuff that Heather just
mentioned super practical tips we can
all start implementing today but give
yourself grace just think about me think
like Mel is working through this - Mel
doesn't want to do this either and she's
doing it today and we can do that
together as a process because it is
really important you're gonna see such a
huge difference I've seen such a huge
difference from implementing the
strategies that heather has been
teaching me over the last year and so
time blocking heather has a lot more
tips but time blocking is definitely one
of the biggest ones that we are like
pushing everybody on our team to do so I
just wanted to say from my perspective
Heather that like what you're teaching
is really really valuable but we have to
have grease on ourselves yeah it's
really important to Mel and I like that
someone said in the chat you know oh
yeah I tried blocking once and it was
really hard again this like Mel said
this is something to work at but but
when you start to implement it as a
regular habit in your lifestyle you will
start to see your projects move faster
you'll start to see be able to start
checking things off I say to the to move
your to-do list your - done list it's so
important that you start to recognize
that you own your time and you get to
choose what you want to do with it and
it's really important to remember that
even if you try it once and you're like
that that wasn't really fun it's not
like managing my time is not actually a
fun thing I only do it because the
discipline of doing it has allowed me to
see results in my life this is something
that we are not taught in schools this
is not something that is regularly
taught and so it doesn't feel fun and
and the thing about time locking that I
think is really
or that we know is that it doesn't mean
that every week has to look the same or
every month has to look the same it's
just that you are being intentional
let's really look at that word it's
about being intentional with your time
and in being intentional with where you
are spending your energy throughout the
day if you have a nine-to-five and you
have to be there
that's great do your best in the
nine-to-five time block within that time
but what are you doing the other hours
of the day are you filming videos are
you recording your your your sales video
are you for you for your course are you
editing are you collaborating with
brands like what are you doing in those
other hours and by being intentional and
being focused is where you'll start to
see success well I'm fired up now do we
have some questions coming in this is
the QA show this is where we just drink
some water and we just talk and I'm just
so grateful that you're here tonight for
this for this live stream but Mel throw
a question or two at me yes okay Heather
I know you are gonna love this question
because Heather is very passionate about
this we work really really hard I think
media and if you are part of we I see
some VRA people in the chat and
everything you know that we're working
really hard behind the scenes but been
famous asks how do you prioritize rest
and Heather's passion about this because
as hard as our team works she makes us
prioritize our rest as well so Heather
can you give us some practical tips and
some mindset tips for how you do that
definitely and this is something I have
had to work on for the last decade as an
entrepreneur and growing into motherhood
and all of the things and um it was
something that I did not do well at
first it was something that I was like
oh other people can operate on four
hours a day and I thought so can i but
here's the thing we're we're not in this
for the next year or the next two years
this this is a marathon like we are here
and we want to help people for the long
haul for the years to come and your body
needs rest and I'm the type of person
let me know in the chat if you feel like
this I have a hard time shutting it off
like I'm always thinking I'm always
doing I feel guilty a lot of times when
I'm resting
but I've had to really shift my mind in
that part of doing this part of being a
creator is that you need to be in run
seasons and in rest seasons now our team
just got out of an extremely hard run
season we ran a 7-day free YouTube
influence challenge and it was a run we
were sprinting we were going it was a
lot of coffee it was a lot of late
nights and early mornings but then right
on the back of that was rest it was
let's shorten our days what needs to get
done how can we refocus where our
priorities are and I think this is a
really big part of becoming successful
it's the understanding that if you're
burning the candle at both ends
eventually it's gonna burn out like if
you're burnt like think about that
burning the candle at both ends is
analogy that means the fuse is going in
in in in you're burning at both ends and
then finally it's done and I don't want
that for you I don't want that for your
family part of being able to recognize
rest in your life is understanding that
it is a requirement for living you need
to sleep you need to write reset your
brain you need to wake up focused being
so burnt out and not able to actually
focus isn't going to do anything for you
or the people you're trying to serve and
I think it's really important that we
recognize that sleep is important that
taking some time in nature is important
that getting up and moving our bodies
it's important to the beings that we are
as humans and so I really just want to
encourage you that understanding that
rest is important in your life and
starting to implement that now is
something that will help you as a habit
as you grow successfully in your future
and again I did not do this well I
remember the days where I was like
crying to my husband thinking how am I
gonna do all this I'm so stressed out
I'm so overwhelmed and really it was
like tired eyes rarely see a bright
future go to sleep get some sleep and
wake up in the morning and it will be
different like to me that's what I keep
thinking and so I just want to encourage
you to be
rested I sleep eight hours a night like
minimum eight hours every single night
there are some nights that I don't when
I had little ones and that was a whole
nother thing but for right now in the
season of life that I'm in it I rest
eight hours a night and I do that
because I have people depending on me
and my brain is an important muscle that
needs to be worked and so I want to make
sure that I am up that I am ready that
I'm vibrant that I am here for the life
that's given to me because that is what
is important so I hope that really helps
you I understand rest is really hard
especially in our society right now
where we have these things attached to
us all the time and we have dark seasons
in our family we have electronic time we
have non electronic time because we want
to be making sure that we are using our
minds in other ways and that we are
really just resting we're turning it off
and we're just stressing I'm preaching
to myself I am preaching to myself Mel
right now because I have a week's
vacation coming up and I just sold mail
yesterday I was like I mean I'm kind of
on vacation and she's like no no no and
having someone in your life that can
help hold you accountable is a big deal
because I would work all the time
because I love what I do and you
probably love what you do too but there
needs to be seasons of rest and run in
your business and your life what do you
think Mel I'm preaching to myself like I
said yep yeah no I have to tell Heather
all the time that no you're not allowed
to work right now it's like she said she
loves her job and this is something that
we all have to work on as people that
are like extremely passionate about what
we do but I been famous is response to
to your answer heather was I never feel
like I deserve to rest helpful I never
feel like I deserve to rest I have to
work all the time to demonstrate my
value and achieve my goals but good rest
is so important go ahead other yeah so
good okay so let's just break that down
and it was been correct Mel Ben yes yeah
so Ben here's what I want you to know uh
I am a woman of faith and I want to just
let you know this that your worth is not
in your work your worth is not in your
work you deserve rest
and just because other people are
telling you you need to work hard you
new crush you need to hustle 18 hours a
day that's their life and that might not
be your life and a lot of times we're
when we're pulling in the I don't
deserve rest it's that feeling that well
our worth is planted in the things that
we do and I want you to know your worth
is not in your work your worth is in who
you are as a human being and so for me
rest is a part of the gift of being
alive hear me it's a
you can use our bodies that we can use
our brains that we can use our hands we
can use our creativity but at the same
time we are given the gift of rest and
so if you're feeling like your worth is
attached to your work I want to just
encourage you to dive into that to
really seek out why you have that
connection and understand I'm here to
tell you that it is not tied to your
work your worth is in the being that you
are that is not a point that for me that
is like a line drawn in the sand that
whether I produce work or whether I do
the work or whether I hustle my face off
is not going to depend on if I deserve
the rest because my body needs it it is
a part of our bodies we need water we
need food and we need sleep
we need rest we need recharge that is a
part of the human process and so I want
to encourage you and I really really
want you to lean into resting it's a big
deal and I want you to just take some
time and practice what does that look
like for you and I want you to be
thinking about the voices that are in
your head are people telling you you
have to hustle you all hear that message
for me I think you should be working
hard but resting hard too I think it's
important to know the season of life
that you're in and know that you may
have like I do three kids at home and
you can't work 15 hours a day I can't
work as much as Mel would want to work
she she doesn't have the three kids and
and all the things happening that I do
so we're in a different season of life
so it may look different for you but I
just want to reiterate that one more
time
you deserve rest you deserve to rest
your body and your mind and your worth
is not tied to your work I knew that
that was gonna get together because
Heather and I actually just had this
conversation last this is like I don't
even know what it was I move what time
is it what day is it yeah but I admitted
to Heather that this is like something I
struggle with as well and the reason
that I will work you know early morning
to late at night every day every week is
because actually honestly that's a
reflection
a lot of times of when I'm in a bad
mental space because I'm not you know
intentional and like Heather mentioned
that word earlier she's you know saying
that we have to be intentional with our
time and so what I wind up doing is you
know when I'm not in like a great space
like I said in my more unhealthy seasons
is like I'll wind up working a super
late at night but I'm working at like a
half capacity or like one-third capacity
and I'm just you know trying to eke out
whatever I can do or I'm avoiding other
things like this is getting deep here
but this is real and like this is true
like that's what I do I will avoid other
stuff because I see like my value and my
work just like you were saying been my
my worth is in my work and so I realized
that I was actually you know this is
something I'm constantly realizing and
struggling with but like if I'm working
at half capacity for six hours like
actually it's so much better if I had
just gone to bed and gone up an hour
earlier and worked really hard and
actually worked at like 90% capacity
instead and busted out the same amount
of work in an hour and had given myself
a chance my brain a chance to take a
rest my body a chance to rest and just a
like a chance to your brain to wander
you know um
neurological research shows the
importance of letting your brain wander
and if we are constantly just focusing
on you know whatever working on so say
it like if you are a sports youtuber and
you are reporting on soccer and all day
every day all you're doing is consuming
soccer content from you know the 6 a.m.
or maybe you have a real job but from
the time that you get off work until I
reeled ups that's a bad habit of saying
that maybe you have a nine-to-five other
job and then you know from all your
spare time all you're ever doing is
thinking about soccer and your channel
and optimizing it then actually what
happens is you know we lose a little bit
of our creativity and our brain craves
and our brain needs some diversity and
our brain needs time to just relax just
sit outside go on a hike go you know lay
in bed you know don't consume things
don't just watch TV and veg out
like give your brain a chance to just
wander and just think about things we
all need that and we often nor stuffing
our brains constantly full of content
and constantly full of other things and
oftentimes it's a distraction that we're
intentionally doing because we don't
want to deal with whatever we're feeling
or whatever is going on our life but we
need to give our time our brains time to
wander and rest it is it is very very
proven once they proven is not for sure
but it's demonstrated in research like
like I said neurological research that
that time is necessary and so when
Heather says rest it's it's about
sleeping but it's also about giving our
brain that chance to to just you know
and that's when your creative thoughts
are gonna spark that's why people say
like your best ideas come when you're in
the shower it's because you're finally
you're not consuming content and you're
not just watching something else and
watching somebody else create or reading
that latest article that has to do with
it your topic like that's when those
creative gears start actually turning is
when you actually are giving yourself a
chance so that's like my little tangent
but this is big then because obviously
this is something Heather and I both
deal with on a regular basis and you
know all of this fits into time
management because that's you know
Heather forces us to block time that we
are taking off and that were resting
because though she tries to I I was
gonna say or I try to actually and it
really is just a labor of love to to our
team but just to people in my life
because it's so good to be intentional I
love being intentional alright Mel any
other questions coming in tonight that
we should answer for the think marketing
show you can drop the questions in the
chat or if you're watching on the replay
you can leave your questions in the
comment section we talked about our
three apps that we love and three tips
for time management yes okay so we had
another question and it's kind of
similar to Ben's but I think you'll have
a few more tips on it Heather and it is
about being really tired so what happens
if after work you know you need to work
on your channel or on your business but
you are exhausted how do you get
yourself motivated to keep working yeah
wow what a really great question and I
would start by
really analyzing when the best time for
you to work on your channel is for me
working on my channel would not be after
my like full-time job it would not that
would not be great because my brains
already done from all the creative work
that I currently am doing and so for me
the best time for me to work on my
channel is actually early mornings and
on the weekends those are due to me are
the best times because my mind is fresh
I have all these ideas I'm ready to get
to it and and so when you're feeling
really tired here's a couple things one
I would this is like you're like where's
she going with this you need to drink
water let's start there like a lot of
times we get really really tired because
we're actually not consuming enough
water that can help our brains to help
us stay focused so number one make sure
you're drinking water number two figure
out what time of day works best for you
now again ice I don't sacrifice sleep I
go to bed early so I can wake up early
because I tend to do a lot better early
in the morning so what time works best
for you so number one are you getting
enough water at number two are you tired
at number three when you're scheduling
these scheduling your things in batches
so for me if I'm gonna be recording
videos I will use a Saturday morning
let's say or Sunday after Sunday
afternoon sometimes but mostly on
Saturday mornings and that's what I'll
do a batch recording and I'll record
three to four videos when I'm doing that
and I do that because if I only have
that one day to get that that actual
intentional work of filming in I want to
do it when I'm at my best when the kids
are out of the house when I've got good
lighting when I'm already dressed with
makeup on and all the things so I want
to be planned so I'll use my week to
plan and/or different days of the week
to plan and then I'll do my videos and
then I'll take the early mornings to get
up with a cup of coffee and get my
editing done so I like to do that and I
I've done it before where I had to do it
at night and crush it until you know
10:00 or 11:00 so that I could get that
editing done I don't do my best work
during that time and so I know that I
get my best work done in the morning so
before I come to think media before I do
what I'm doing here I will work in
on the projects that I want to move
forward so that's what I would say if
you're feeling tired and again
everything in seasons
everyone's at a different level
everyone's starting at a different level
everyone is working through different
things in their life and so don't
compare where you are to where someone
else is so if you're like I'm just
feeling so tired take a day off take a
weekend it's okay it'll be there when
you get back but if you if you are
feeling like I just can't get this done
at night when I'm home because I'm
already tired and all the things then
can you go to bed not can I stay up and
watch Netflix until midnight or 1:00
o'clock that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying can you go to bed early and can
you wake up early so you could be
focused on those projects in the morning
I hope that helps you that's been some
things that have worked for me Mel I
know you try and crush it at 92 but
again like you said it's like you're
working at half capacity so it's better
to just wake up in the morning with a
fresh brain go to bed early right Mel
that's another thing people who always
move that little that little line
they're like well I'm still tired well
you're going to bed it what o'clock at
them in the morning I go to bed at 8:30
almost every night and the nights that
I'm up late I'm like Who am I I am a
zombie when I wake up because I just I
just can't go that fast yeah I actually
have a thought on this too because
something that I I do have um Heather
and I both have side channels most the
people in the company do and you know we
were just talking about the kind of pace
that we run at think media and yet we
have our side business is that we each
work on and you know we want to practice
what we teach in multiple ways we
practice it on think media but we also
practice it in our on our own channels
and so what I found is something that
helps me is I will pick like a small
task that I can do after work on that
day and so yes I'm not gonna be trying
to probably record a full video or you
know do all that creative thinking like
Heather mentioned after a long day
because that is really tough but I'll
try to do like a like pick some task I
can do and what it does is again it's or
like talking about working on our
muscles and so I'm actually like
expanding my capacity and when I you
know get off work at 5:00 p.m. save you
know you're a normal person you might
get off at 5:00
yeah I don't know when everyone gets off
work but you get off at that time and
then you go home and you just want a
claps and you just want a binge TV for a
couple hours you know maybe you have
kids like everyone has different
situations but if that is you if you are
somebody who you know generally just
feels like you're really low energy and
that's what you gravitate towards you
gravitate towards binging on your phone
or binging on Netflix or something like
that try just setting yourself a small
manageable goal and get one thing done
like maybe it's like do a little bit of
research something that doesn't take
tons of effort doesn't take tons of
brain energy but you can at least get
something off of your list and just do
it for like half an hour or an hour and
then give yourself time to do whatever
else you need your rest and everything
but for me I have found that giving
myself those small manageable tasks to
do throughout the week actually helps me
like I said it kind of expands my
capacity and my ability to you know work
a little bit longer you know on my side
channel and we know we're talking about
rest so there's all a balance but
depending what season you're in as
Heather mentioned you know where you are
if you're that person who identifies
with like I just crash and I just lay on
the couch this is a way that maybe you
can you know work on getting that energy
up and everything after work in a day
yep and I recognize that there's the
tasks in my life that are what we call
high energy and low energy tasks so I
want to put the high energy tasks when I
I'm I bet when I'm at my best that's
really what I want to do one of my low
energy tasks like answering the comments
on YouTube and social media am i when I
don't have to necessarily be on my top
game in terms of the energy output that
I need to do and someone said you know
what about your food I won't go to like
crazy things here but we consider the
job that we do as professionals
important and the nutrition that we have
is just as important well just says and
I'm not comparing myself to Kobe Bryant
but just Kobe Bryant exercises eats well
because his body is his is his
profession so is mine the level of
output that I'm putting out to the world
is important like me having energy right
now on this live at 4:00 p.m. on a
Tuesday
is important at 5:00 p.m. on a Tuesday
is important and so I need to make sure
that I'm dialed in with making sure I'm
putting good things in so that at the
same time I would have good energy if I
ate crappy food which I've done I have
in my life when I've eaten crappy foods
I don't feel energized to want to do it
when I don't exercise
I don't feel energized to want to put
out puts out into the world so yeah that
is a big part of it too and I love that
we're seeing this correlation between
time management and the effects that it
has on our bodies and our minds and our
spirits and it's just really wonderful
to be part of the think marketing
community where you are all about R and
R as well all right Mel let's answer a
couple more questions and then we will
sign off for the night yeah so I'm
learning in technology is wondering if
Cheetos and Red Bulls are not your
recommended diet thing
no actually chose a Red Bull told me no
I mean you do you boo that's that's a
big but but I mean yeah I've definitely
had the seasons of crushing the Red
Bulls or drinking too much coffee
actually from our seven-day youtube
challenge I drink so much coffee that
the whole next week after I had
headaches in the afternoon because I was
drinking three cups to keep myself going
throughout the whole day and the next
week I had what is it caffeine crash
because my body was reregulate
had to do way more water just to
reregulate it back to normal
and I mean I'm not recommending I'm not
a doctor I'm not prescribing this for
you I'm just saying that she knows
arrival might not be those nourishing
things your your body or your mind all
right this is a such a great question
and Heather I know that you are also
going to have a power answer for this
elbow I am setting that bar high like oh
well our answer come on it's working
felt like really setting me up right now
a power answer okay because this is
something that I know you have to work
with every day
so Alba is asking how do you deal with
unplanned or unexpected
interruptions you know specifically
maybe with children and you know I know
you have a dog and we have a lot of
other things going on our life so how do
you deal with those interruptions hmm
okay so I have a couple things for you
elbow Mel was it specific about kids
because I do have something specific
about kids say that okay here we go
all right Alva so here's a couple things
one in my home in our home we our words
matter and so we actually want to set
our kids up for success meaning that
like right now I'm on a live stream they
are doing something that is planned that
they know they can do we've set the
expectations and the rules within what
that looks like now for our family words
matter and so we don't want our kids to
feel like a burden or feel we don't want
to get upset with them we want to
instruct them of how to have good
self-control so here's that you're like
okay I thought we were talking about
time management Heather's giving
parenting tips here me so your words
matter so when your kids come at you and
they're like hi mommy mommy mommy and
you're like oh you're so annoying they
hear that I know they hear that so my
advice to you is to take a breath and
understand what is the distraction at
hand
is it that your kiddos they just
actually need you and what is more
important in that time if my kids came
to me right now and they're like mom I
need you mom I need you I would kindly
mute my mic with the smile on my face
mommy's busy right now but I will get to
you right after I'm done like I have
certain things that I will say to them
so that they know what that looks like
and I have had that toddlers around me
all of filming and you know all those
things I've had that life so I
understand that you're like oh I'm being
so distracted it's an expectations thing
so how higher expectations and if you
have kids and dogs and things around you
say when you're filming what's the
expectation in that time frame so I hope
that helped you with that part of it but
distractions throughout the day this is
my whole day I feel like I'm just
putting out fires all day long and it's
and sometimes it can be very distraction
distraction distracting oh my gosh got
that one out it
be very distracting it is communicating
with the people in your life also what
are you allowing to distract you so
someone sent you a text message that's a
distraction that you have allowed to be
in your time block it's you've allowed
that to be intentionally in your time
block I don't have my a text message on
right now I don't have my phone on me
it's all it's off to the side so I'm not
gonna intentionally be distracted so
that is like an outward distraction
coming in then there are like actual
real things like oh my gosh the kid just
broke his arm we need to go to the
hospital okay well then we stop what
we're doing and we put our focus on that
new thing if you're working on a team or
you're working with your spouse or
you're working with other people
communicating what you're doing when
you're doing it where you are in the
project in some capacity will cut down
on a lot of the distractions so if you
need to write the emails for your email
sequence you need to calendar block that
and then communicate this is dark
writing time I am unavailable during
these times like I don't know if you
remember way way way back in the day
like when our parents did not have cell
phones when they didn't have cell phones
they could literally just be sitting
around doing whatever they wanted until
the actual phone rang that you had the
choice if you wanted to answer or not
like we have allowed so many
distractions to be a comment to be a
part of our lives so just try and set up
your time communicate it wisely and
watch your words that's what I would say
in what that looks like for you and it's
always a learning process and I think a
big part of it is the level of
expectation I remember we were on a
seven day challenge a few weeks ago it
was like live number 43 I don't know we
were live so many times and my dog got
out of his little pin and he was running
around in here and then my kid ran
behind him and I'm like live teaching
like I am right now and there's like
chaos happening behind me and I'm like
well this is my life this is where we
are and I just kind of laughed it off
because it's also just real life I mean
really at the same time like we are so
blessed that you get to do what you do
and we get to do what we do and that we
get to serve people and we get to make
videos we get to help people
we get to be a part of communities and
we get to do all those things that is a
blessing so if you're in the think media
think marketing community I would hope
that you would see that the level of
expectation that you have for the people
and the things around you are that
you're someone number one setting
expectations for what's important but
number two you're having grace for the
things that happen in your life all
right I could go on on that one Mel but
we'll leave it at that
digging down into the core issues of
what some of these these questions
unveil is it's so important and it might
seem like come on I just want to know
you know how to you know make all those
distractions stop unfortunately that we
don't have an answer for that that's not
gonna happen
Heather is basically a super superhero
but you should not stop all the
distractions from coming in and if you
were on the challenge you know what
we're talking that was a big recurring
theme and you know we just have to
really tackle like those hard issues and
everything that comes up so that we like
Heather mentioned how the patients we
have priorities and we can like you know
find that some peace as we're dealing
with all those issues that are gonna
naturally come up so we have another
question that says this is from Grenada
wellness can time broccoli work when
working a full-time job within
consistent hours I start work around the
same time but the time I can I leave can
differ by one to five hours whoa yeah so
I actually when I time block and what I
recommend that you try and do is I I
don't time block day by day
oh how they I think you're muted sorry
the world okay so if you that's an
inside joke sorry okay so if your time
blocking let me go back if you are time
blocking and I time block throughout the
week so I before the week even starts I
time block what the next week is going
to be that sets my intention for the
next week it allows me to pre-plan the
projects it allows me to think through
what is gonna be happening what is this
gonna look like how am I gonna feel how
do I want to show up for the world those
are all things that I intentionally do
I'm just telling you to time block you
don't to do all that but that is where
this is gonna go in how we use our time
wisely and so I time walk through the
week so if you know that on Monday you
leave it one and on Wednesday you leave
it seven and on Friday you leave it to
those time blocks your nine-to-five
should be blocked in there and then you
have the time in the morning and then
you have the time after that and then
you have the time on the weekends and so
or on the weekdays spending on what your
working schedule is so really be
intentional about what am i doing around
those times when I'm driving home am i
listening to a course that I purchased
am i listening to a podcast or am I just
listening to music because I needed to
to unwind like what are you doing during
your commute not that we have commutes
at this very moment but if you have one
like what are you doing during that time
when you get home what do you want to do
how do you want to be when you get home
do you want to use the evening to do
some research when you're doing research
what's your time limit like I set
everything around to the time because
you can get lost in saying well I'm in a
research on on how to do X Y & Z well
how many videos are you gonna watch like
I intentionally think about all these
things and it seems very micromanage but
it's so intentional because it allows me
to make sure that my energy is really
focused on what I'm trying to accomplish
so when you're doing time blocking first
start with the big rocks that's what you
wanna start with what's your big rock so
if your big rock number one is that you
work a regular 9 to 1 or 9:00 to 5:00 or
or 10 to 4 or whatever that looks like
for you for your employer then put those
big rocks on there but then be thinking
about what are the other rocks around
do you need exercise when are you gonna
do that when are you gonna shower after
that like these are things I think about
when I'm thinking about that for me
you'll notice on my time block family
time was huge that was huge for me
because I have little ones and I valued
the time that I get to spend with them
so I'm gonna make sure that I'm working
twice as hard within the work blocks so
that I can be intentional about the time
that I have in my family time so I would
hope that helps you when you when you
think about what it looks like to be
time blocking but we time block at a
week per time like intentional time
locking at a week time because every
week can look different but that's the
best way to do that start with your big
rocks first and then start filling them
in but I recommend excuse me I recommend
that when your time blocking that you
don't have more than like five main
blocks like five main things that are on
your calendar you can have little things
here and there like I gotta go to the
dentist I need to do my taxes like you
can add that stuff on there but at the
same time you want to make sure you're
intentional about what the big rocks are
on your time block yeah and so if you
are somebody that has like a flexible
schedule or yeah you work a lot of
overtime like brain and wellness is
interesting that's why I'm not sure if I
said this that's why we love doing
digital calendars yes the block so if
you have blocked all this time but then
you wind up getting home two hours later
you just move the block around and you
just have to find work so if you're
truly blocking the most important things
yeah that that might just be the way
that your life is and you can't control
that and so you're just gonna have to
bump it around that's what I do because
this job oftentimes will have a lot of
things that come up that I can't
necessarily control so okay I don't I
can't do that today now it has to move
to you know two days later and yes it
might bump my schedule but that's just
what I have to do right now so journey
to wellness was giving some follow-up
details on his question so I just wanted
to mention that as well
Yeah right oh go ahead Heather oh is
this a yeah digital that's why that is
the reason we love digital because I
remember doing it really pretty like I
love pretty journals I really wish I
could do a pretty journal but but I
think life is beyond the prettiness
right like my life gets messy and so in
order to keep that organized to keep the
chaos organized digital helps because
you can have it but you can share it
with other people I think that's a big
part of it too is that I don't just have
access to my calendar my kids have
access my husband has access my all my
team has access because I need them to
see where I have put my intention in
what I want to be working on and I love
that digital can be moved around it
could be mobile it's not like you have
to carry around a calendar in your purse
if you have a purse it's it's its own
piece that you can work off of
yeah and vege a vixen was asking do you
have a specific app or just a calendar
app that uses a time block we just use
Google Calendar it's easy most of us I
mean so many of us have a gmail account
it's free and it's so accessible so like
how they was just mentioning was sharing
it to people since so many people have
Gmail already in Google Calendar you can
just it's so easy to share it and it's
really accessible there's a lot of
features I'm somebody was asking about
all Heather's different colors on her
calendar so that's it's all easy to
color coordinate you just if you've
already put in all your events you
right-click on the event go in and
change the color of it and you can pick
custom colors so all those features are
really easily available and we love a
free app so yeah and I have tried let me
tell you I have tried like almost all
the calendars that are on the market
like calendar apps that are on the
market because I was like oh well I
should integrate my grocery list with my
calendar and you're like I should do all
these things and I think Mel just hit it
right on the head like Google calendars
so good because it's free and because
majority of people have some type of
Google access and we will have more
google calendar tutorials coming soon
here on the think marketing show so
we'll be walking through how to set it
up how to use it properly all of the
hacks and tips you can have with that
but I think colors are great because it
allows your brain to write melody I know
it's a brain thing but it allows your
brain to separate those things rather
than all being just like one color block
of your things I do not and that yeah
and I think this
question actually flows really naturally
out of what we were just talking about
and could it's the idea of it being so
frustrating when you don't accomplish
what was on your calendar or what your
time blocking was or what was on your
to-do list like how do you deal with
that and I just want to say like from my
perspective that really quickly and this
is something I really struggle with
because honestly as soon as my calendars
off or my to-do list is I just want to
throw it I don't I don't want to look at
it throw it all out the window that is
like natural inclination clearly not the
right way to handle it
and again so this is like my practical
tip and then all that Heather speak to
this but my practical tip is move it oh
I didn't get that done today I'm moving
it to tomorrow I have a physical I have
like a notebook that I write down my
personal - dues for every day so it's
like my my laundry my grocery list
whatever if it didn't get done I move it
to the next day and that's just how we
do it we just have to move things
because that's how they was just
mentioning it is real life and your
thought is gonna happen and I'm very
sorry to tell you you are not gonna get
everything on your to-do list on every
day I mean not to put that on you but I
want to prepare you if you're in this
you know in this industry and this
creative industry and this crazy world
of YouTube you're gonna have so many
things that come up that you need to get
done and so just be prepared to move
things over digital move it over yeah I
mean let's even take today as an example
like this is real life we couldn't
figure this stream was not connecting it
was supposed to start at 4:00 it ended
up starting it like I don't know what
time for 24 30 I don't know what time is
it 5:00 I don't know what time it
started but we had to like tear it down
and rebuild it and we were and I was
getting frustrated then I was like you
know what it's okay like this is okay
it's okay that we're late we're still
doing this the things I have that I'm
supposed to be doing later we'll just
move those to another day and it's all
in how you handle it it's all in how you
you are receiving it or or letting it go
actually the sign you're receiving it's
letting it go because real life was real
life and you know they're like we won't
I would hope that my to-do list is never
done I would hope that
and the reason is is because I always
want to be working on something I always
want to have a new project I always want
to be excited about something I always
want to organize my kitchen or I always
want to have something new and fun to be
working on and excited about because
guys life is worth living like this is
okay and I think because we've just been
taught that we need to finish the list
we need to check all the boxes we need
to do all the things I would ask you to
think about where does that come from
and are you okay with feeling
disappointed in the things you didn't
get done in the day versus rewarding
yourself for the things that you did get
done you know like think about the
things you did accomplish today we we we
launched a new course today and so to be
mad at myself because the things I have
later on today need to move to tomorrow
would be discrediting the work and
effort that it took to do the other
things and so I just want to implore you
to really be unwind unraveling where is
that where are those feelings coming
from and are you only focusing on the
things you didn't do today and are you
not even recognizing the good that you
did
I mean maybe today all you did was call
your mom maybe that's actually what
needed to happen like maybe today all
you did was write the email reward
yourself you did it and so the things
you have to do tomorrow they can move to
try they can move to next week they can
move to three weeks from now your life
is worth living and it's worth
celebrating and it's worth achieving
small goals to get to the big things and
we're on a journey it's not like I'm
gonna finish my to-do list and then sit
there and be like well now what do I do
like I hope it is forever running
because that's what we're here to do
we're here to create we're here to serve
we're here to try new things and fail on
some projects and win it some projects
and push things around and it's all a
challenge but it's all in how you see it
yep so good that's something again that
Heather is just coaching me on on a
regular basis because I feel you I
really feel that question a lot and I'm
like just move it over and like acting
like I have answer but no I I really
struggle with that and like I said my
natural inclination if I don't get
something done my to-do list it gets
mess it's like messed up in my head I'm
like okay this is all out the window but
it is really coming down to it's a
mindset change in ourselves like
Heather's is talking to us about and so
I hope that you guys are getting value
out of this and I hope that you know we
were all able to really internalize the
encouragement that Heather is giving us
let me know in the chat what you guys
are thinking and we're gonna actually
finish things out strong with just a
couple power questions Heather you ready
- I think we're questions yeah our
questions would really what I mean is
we're gonna do a lightning round of just
trying to answer the last few questions
here so then we can jump off and Heather
can get some dinner and finish some work
for today right we've got a lot going on
today so if you guys want to keep
connecting with us keep asking us
questions about this topic then I just
want to let you know a few different
places where we are available for you so
on this think marketing channel we have
the community tab for you guys where we
are going to ask you a question we're
gonna let you know like hey what
questions did you have about today's
stream and then we're gonna be popping
in there and trying to answer some more
of your questions now we won't be able
to answer all of them but the amazing
part about social media is the rest of
the community is there to also help
answer your questions and we have
amazing people in this community we have
business owners we have other just
top-notch powerful creators and so they
will also be in the comments and we will
all be able to talk chat together if you
want to keep going deeper on this topic
we also have social media so we have
Heather on Instagram she's that Miss
Heather Torres mrs. Heather Torres sorry
it's MRA it's Mrs so is that miss or
misses I don't even know what the real
thing is I'm married that's all I know
about so we can find Heather on
Instagram and mrs. Heather Torres and
also Shawn kennel on Instagram and so we
just love to connect with you guys there
because we have more opportunities as we
are making posts and we're engaging in
these questions we want to
these conversations going this isn't a
one and done this isn't like okay good
we've got time management checked off
our list this is something we want to
grow with you guys in and we want to
hear about your progress so always shot
us out tagged Heather tagged Shawn so we
can see your time blocking calendar take
a picture and let us know because we
want to be able to celebrate on that
progress with you guys but alright we're
gonna finish off with a couple questions
heather athlete remedy is asking what's
a good present percentage of working on
your IPAs so what's what's an IPA either
for a six point two s what's a good
percentage of working on your IPAs your
income producing activities versus just
the work that needs to go into your
channel and and what's so I think
athlete remedy is asking about IPAs in
your business so in the business side of
things versus like creating content for
your YouTube channel
hmm yeah so an IPA is an
income-producing activity which means it
is something that's actually going to
move the dollar sign in your bank
account that's the best way to move it
like did you land the client did you get
the brand deal did you send the emails
to your webinar so that you can get
people inside of your membership program
like that is an IPA that's an
income-producing activity so what is the
percentage that you should be working on
your IPAs versus the normal work well my
goal is to work on an IPA a day at least
one IPA a day because depending on what
that looks like in your role and in what
you're doing that could look different
for everyone so to give you a proper
percentage wouldn't actually justify the
whole question so I would say start with
one get it done by one that's my thing
always done by one so what can you get
done first thing in the morning what can
you get done first there's a book called
eat that frog I think everyone should
read it it's about doing the hard things
that you don't want to do that you
actually have to do usually those are
the things we want like to push off we
like to do all the other things that we
don't actually need to do so my
recommendation for you is to work on at
least one income-producing activity a
day read the book eat that frog and then
work on getting things done by 1:00 if
your day ended at 1:00 and all you had
was the rest of the afternoon to go
surfing or
hang out with your kids or go on a hike
with your dogs if everything was done by
one what has to get done in your
business because a lot of things are
good to dues but they're not have to do
so awesome ok I was lightning Mel are
you proud of me that was a lightning
question that was pretty good now the
real challenge is going to be going
through this next question as a
lightning question because I get both
could speak to this quite a lot but um
this isn't actually even a question so
this is unsolicited advice I'm sorry
social life but I wanted to speak to
this a little bit because social life
was saying it's just really hard with
all the different things going on and
it's frustrating trying to balance
everything they have like a full-time
job and this is not not to call you
outta talks I'm not sure what exactly
you do have going on but I think that
this sentiment is very very common and
we talked to so many youtubers on a
daily basis and this statement right
here that once I have more time I'll be
able to grow my channel better and not
and again I'm not calling you out
because again I don't know it is true
that statement is true but we talked to
so many youtubers and this is such a
recurring theme someday I'll have enough
time I'll be able to get into my channel
I'll be able to really pour the time
into doing this right hether debunk the
statement give us some thoughts on that
yeah oh man ok lightning round here we
go lightning round
ok so um when I have time one day when I
have time then I'll that is a really
dangerous statement because as you grow
as your YouTube channel grows as your
influence grows as your business grows
you're always going to be set up with
new problems to solve and there unless
you can get a grip on how you currently
handle your time it's going to feel the
same as it grows I don't have enough
time now you actually won't have enough
time then because time is so relative to
how you are using it and so when you say
and I I feel you I know what this I'm
always like so I catch myself I'm
we have another team member when we're
done with this thing when we get another
editor wet like when those things happen
I'll have more time to XY and Z and it
actually is just a cover up for me not
actually figuring out what is the actual
problem what am i working on that's not
actually producing anything it's the
80/20 rule 80% of your time should be
worked which should be within the blocks
that produce 20% of the outcomes 80% of
your time should be working on what
produces No yeah 80% your time or
produces the most amount of your of your
income that's what that's like the best
way to say it so like when you look
alike 80/20 80% of what you're doing is
usually producing No 20% I'm saying it
all backwards because I don't have the
visual in front of me I'm flipping it
okay rewind this is how they're in real
life rewind okay what you're spending
your most time on needs to be producing
the most okay
so usually 80% of what you're working on
isn't actually producing anything like
it's not actually moving the needle 20%
is actually producing 80% of the outcome
it's called the 80/20 rule you should
look it up 8020 rule so when you are
thinking about oh I just don't feel like
I have enough time I want you to take
the challenge this week to write down
every single hour what you worked on I
know it sounds tedious and crazy but I
guarantee you that by the end of the
week you will have things on that list
that you will look at and go well that
was a waste of time and I want you to
circle what was a waste of time and then
I want you to go the next week and do it
again and see did you have less things
that were a waste of time because no
matter what whether it's right now
whether it's in one year whether it's in
ten years the time that you have in the
day is all that you have the 24 hours so
right now the first thing to do is
figuring out how are you wasting time
how can you increase the profits so that
you can do the next thing which is buy
time how do you buy time with people
with people with people
so how do I get it all done in a day
I don't do about myself I don't clean my
house I don't shop
I don't do the groceries I don't do
those things I have purchased time other
people do those things because for me I
would rather not go to Starbucks I would
rather buy all my things at clearance at
Target so that I could use that money to
buy the time that I would be going to do
things that I feel personally for my own
life no judgment to you you might like
this but no judgment to you the things
that I do in my life that I feel are a
circled waste of time make sense so that
I use that time to do an IPA an
income-producing activity I use that
time to spend time with my kids are you
seeing this so if you're feeling like I
don't have enough time or one day when I
can do this I'll have enough time it's a
mindset it's 24 hours it's a mindset
so right now you may not like the job
that you're in and you want to shift to
being able to do this full-time it's
still gonna be full-time doing this as a
job is like trading in your night into
five for a five tonight okay because
it's not always on your mind you don't
leave the work it's not like your
regular job so I just want you to take
the challenge everyone this week take
the challenge to write down every single
hour what did you do and then at the end
of the week look at it and what was a
waste of time and then can you afford to
start buying time those aren't those
would be my things and that was
lightening around now I did it so
lightning that was lightning now we're
good because we could talk about that
concept for a long time it is a big deal
and so many people in the chat we're
saying this is the tip this is a
knowledge bomb purposeful mindset and I
want you guys to let us know in the
comments what your aha moment was from
today's session we talked about a lot of
different aspects of time management
here and I'm seeing some aha moments in
the chat right now and it's really cool
to me to see that here on a think
marketing podcast or I think marketing
show oh well this is this note we're
just talking about this day on the think
marketing show
on YouTube talking about you know
starting out this video talking about
Google Calendar and we can end with
Heather really honing in on that mindset
shift that most of us are going to need
to take in order to be successful on
YouTube this this journey of being on
YouTube is about more than just you know
trying to crank out a video you guys
have a purpose and I know so many of you
guys in the chat right now have a
message that you need to share with the
world you have something that is gonna
help people and you have so much in you
to share and to bless other people and
so these kinds of tips and everything
that that Heather was sharing today are
what is gonna empower you to bring that
knowledge to other people and so when
you have a purpose-driven mindset when
you have a goal in mind and you have
something that is driving you you'll
overcome the challenges I know it can
seem really hard a lot of people in the
chat tonight we're talking about the
various things that they have going on
in their life that make it really hard
to be committed to this and to be
putting the time into this and so we
know and and we're here for you because
through those things you know those
things are real and they're serious and
as Heather mentioned this might not be
the season where you're going to put ten
hours a week into YouTube that's okay
but ultimately it's about keeping that
long-term eye on the prize you're
looking towards that goal and again just
as Heather was mentioning it's that
purpose driven mindset you are here for
a reason there is a bigger legacy that
you're gonna be leaving online for your
family for your children you have a
legacy to leave and so I am just so
grateful to have been able to spend this
time with you guys today and seeing
everybody's different situations in the
chat and I hope that you guys are here
for the long haul with us so as we
mentioned there's gonna be that that
post on the community tab and let us
know what your stories are what you're
struggling with with time management and
we want to be there to help you guys out
Heather can you land the plane for us I
love this I love the the new mantra one
I
yeah a day exactly that's what I want
you to be working on I love that one IPA
a day I didn't even know I said that but
that is definitely what I work on I mean
like that's what I do so thank you for
drawing that out of me I love these
questions because they help me with that
hey you can catch a the think marketing
podcast every single Tuesday we drop it
here on the youtube channel as well as
anywhere that you can listen to iTunes
or know that you can listen to podcasts
like iTunes and Spotify and anywhere
podcasts are audible so you can listen
to that and today's episode just dropped
and this morning and it was all about
our content our think media content
should we break down how we create
videos like what do we actually say in
the videos why it's important and the
order of things that need to happen and
the mistakes that we see so many
creators making so if you did not listen
or watch that episode you can watch that
one right now after this show thank you
so much for being here and we'll catch
next time